well turning now to a story about Second
Chances in one of the poorest regions of
the country a program there is stringing
lives back together one guitar at a time
Mark Strassman visited not County
Kentucky to learn about these handmade
instruments and the resilient people who
were making them
the locals say Hindman Kentucky is known
for two things
Hunter
[Music]
the mountains ring music a point of
Pride here
and crystal meth an Appalachian sorrow
that was my main priority from the time
my eyes opened as soon as I woke up that
was the first thing was wondering where
I was going to get my my fix for the day
and I just didn't think about anything
else I was consumed in in that world in
a place like this is it hard to get
drugs around here yeah you can go about
anywhere
and find anything he was looking for
Nathan Smith was 18 when he tumbled off
the back of a work truck surgeons
rebuilt his body but painkillers then
meth broke his will and poisoned his
future for the next 20 years
I knew that if something didn't happen
that I was either going to wind up in
prison or I was going to be dead
in not county heinman is the Hub
nearly 700 people scraping by in one of
America's porous Pockets even the local
Creek is trouble in fact it's called
Troublesome Creek
and back in July its flood waters
swamped parts of a county where the
overdose rate nearly triples the
national average I'd say it's probably
about as bad as it gets anywhere it's a
crisis here so the candidates for the
school that you run is almost never
ending sadly will probably never have
any lack of people that are eligible to
go through the program do
zel road is a guitar maker by trade and
a drug rehabber by circumstance he has
12 employees all former drug users some
with felony records They entered a
county rehab program and enrolled in the
school of luthery as part of their
recovery I wonder how deep that goes
you think the rolling pin sander would
take that out since 2012 nasal road has
taken them in taught them Woodworking
and helped them learn to love guitars
mandolins and dulcimers instead of
heroin meth and opioids what is it about
making guitars that helps people the
nature of making guitars is is a it's a
long curve the the gratification is a
not instant opposite of drugs opposite
of drugs you have to commit
a lot of labor-intensive hours to
building a guitar and you have to come
back week after week after week they
find something else to fix on
they find their gratification in it and
as time goes by the memory of the drugs
gratification gets smaller and the hope
of luthery gratification gets bigger you
have to sand this Smith started here in
2017 and became the program's first
full-time employee a lot of people they
find out that you've been on drugs you
know something like they look down on
you and Doug's never done that with
everybody that comes through the door he
gives them he gives them a chance what
about making guitars surprised you I
guess it was just the the craftsmanship
that goes into them when you see what
you can create with your hands they
lifts you up and makes you say that
there is things you can do without using
over the last 10 years more than 200
recovering drug addicts have come
through this program they've helped
build string instruments sold to music
stores across the country like Smith
they've learned to master luthery and
build a second chance most do the
program has a 71 percent success rate so
far you know 71 percent
success rate is also 29 percent failure
rate and there's some heartbreak that
comes in I have to remind myself you
know not everyone can succeed some
people are just not able to break free I
have hope that in their lifetimes they
will be but
maybe not not necessarily while they're
with us I redone them the building we
moved into Smith is one of the success
stories he's remarried started a new
family and became the father he always
wanted to be to his three children
everybody deserves a second chance and
all of us that got a second chance have
turned our life around and turned it
into something amazing we we make these
amazing instruments five years sober yes
congratulations thank you proud of you
thank you keep it up thanks
I wanna fly like a bird and of all
places a guitar shop they've strung
together New Hope and left what was
Troublesome to the creek when it comes
to hope I can sure use
for CBS mornings Mark Strassman Hindman
Kentucky
that was powerful it really was it is
there's something special about working
with your hands yeah it occupies the
mind in a new way and it provides
Pleasures that can be deeper than
anything you get in a syringe or a pill
yeah to go from feeling like you're
hanging on by a string to placing them
on guitars is powerful yeah and just
saying that the memory of doing drug
dissipates once you start creating a new
love for something else yeah that that
really said it to me in a way that I
hadn't heard before it's just remarkable
that he was able to notice what he does
and could translate it to something
that's right it would help his community
I love that that's good